[Music]
Disney Princesses is pretty much our fav
topic ever but did you know what else
was pretty awesome
fan fictions from genderbent too gory
these are some of the best fan fictions
we have ever seen stay tuned for the one
that combines all your favorite Disney
characters and puts them in a
boarding-school
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
these Disney Princess fan fics what kind
of a princess are you gender bend Disney
Princesses let's start with something
we've talked about many times on this
channel have you ever wondered what
Disney Princesses would look like as
princes you absolutely have to check out
some of our past videos but you can also
read about it in fan fictions this fan
fiction can be found on Wattpad and it
was created by a user called and Rihanna
G the fan fiction is a one-shot meaning
each story is one chapter long with some
extending into different parts
altogether there are 24 chapters of
Disney Princesses in a different gender
the story introduces many characters
such as Edward as Elsa Snow as Snow
White Aaron as Ariel and many more each
come with Q individual stories that will
give you a glimpse into an important
event in their life every chapter also
includes you the reader as a part of the
story to make it even more exciting
one of our faves is the one shot with
Jamal who portrays Jasmine we won't
spoil it all for you but this fanfic is
totally appropriate for all ages it's
also one of the most adorable ones we've
ever seen we would absolutely love it if
Disney could do an official gender Bend
with the princesses to brave the frozen
heart fanfiction world is full of
surprises if you've never read a
fanfiction but want to start somewhere
light to brave the frozen heart is a
good one you can find it on archive of
our own org and it's written by green
haired Fae the fan fiction features
several characters including Elsa Anna
Merida Hans and a lot
more use after eating each chapter is
either a continuation of the previous
one or a point of view from another
Disney character but it all comes with
one story Merida falling in love with
Elsa if you know us you know we love a
good love story and we especially love
it when fan fictions put on a different
perspective and have a Disney Princess
fall in love with a woman don't get us
wrong there's nothing wrong with Prince
Charming's of this world but there's
just something special about seeing
traditional Disney characters being
portrayed as part of the LGBT community
if you've dreamed of this happening in
real life you'll probably still have to
wait a couple of years but that's
exactly why this fanfiction was created
the story of Merida falling in love with
Elsa is absolutely adorable and
extremely well-written it's only
limitation is that it's not supposed to
be read by those younger than their
teenage years but other than that it's
absolutely perfect
Beauty and the witch so we already
talked about genderbent stories and a
bit of LGBT romance but what's even
better than that a Harry Potter
crossover that's a combination of both
and you know we love Harry Potter as
much as we love Disney so that
definitely says something beauty and the
which can be found on fanfiction.net it
was written by a user called a Rosa and
it is perfect this story talks about a
character called Morgana mary janes
Potter who's the center of the entire
fanfiction a fair warning this story
does feature Vernon hitting the main
character at the beginning but don't
worry the actual fan fiction comes with
many fun parts imagine making a wish
that Belle was your older sister and
having that wish come true that's
exactly what happens in this story we
also get a glimpse of a Greek goddess
negotiating with Dumbledore about
Morgana's attendance to Hogwarts
basically a bunch of stuff goes down the
story is split into nine extremely long
chapters seriously it's long so make
sure you grab a cup of tea or hot cocoa
get comfortable and have a read of this
amazing Harry Potter Disney crossover
okay the 12 fighting princesses okay but
what's better than a Harry Potter
crossover a Hunger Games crossover
seriously this is one of those stories
you'd never imagined would come to life
but here we are but just imagine seeing
12 Disney princes and 12 Disney
princesses battle it out in the ring
sounds amazing doesn't it this fanfic
belongs to Lee Neelu from fanfiction.net
the story is split into 16 chapters but
the actual games don't happen until
about chapter 6 the first few chapters
give a pretty detailed explanation of
each Disney Princess and Prince and
their district and the best part it's
written in first person each character
gives her own perspective of what's
happening around them at that moment if
you think about it that's much better
than just seeing the games from a
perspective of a single person and trust
us it gets pretty intense just like the
real Hunger Games
unfortunately this story isn't exactly
finished as the last chapter is still
only talking about top eight contestants
so make sure you don't get too attached
but you should still definitely give
this one a read show them how it is done
if you love Black Panther you'll love
this one we just love it when Disney
collides with different worlds but
unfortunately we can't always see that
on our screens well unless you'll be
watching the new record Ralph's movie
but this fanfiction is pretty amazing
you can find it on fanfiction.net it was
created by a talented user called
the cape fangirl guess who joined the
Disney Princess clan Cherie from Black
Panther she is one of our favorite
characters ever and it would definitely
be interesting seeing her as a princess
well she is a princess in this story
Cherie has to attend the Dame Institute
of sophisticated noble elegance of youth
which for short stands for Disney it's
an exclusive club for royalty
in other words princesses since Wakanda
now had to engage with other countries
in order to get on good terms it was
important for Cherie to attend and the
best part we mean of course aside from
Cherie all your favorite princesses are
in this
the story is pretty funny with some
classic Sheree attitude we all love
seriously who doesn't love Charisse
plenty personality just imagine her
interacting with other Disney Princesses
it's definitely time to read show them
how it is done fanfiction so could we
all just wrap it up and go home when my
sister was born we just love happy fan
fictions this one doesn't have any kinds
of crossovers but it's just so heartfelt
we had to add it on our list it was
written by deviantART user called winter
moon 95 the story revolves around Anna
and Elsa and as you can probably guess
it talks about the time when Anna was
born the entire fanfiction has 5
different chapters and each of them is
absolutely adorable there's no fighting
just a good story about a sisterly bond
that cannot be broken we actually never
get to see what Elsa was feeling when
Anna was first born so this is a pretty
awesome story it's perfectly suitable
for all ages to read unfortunately this
story is not finished as the author
notes chapter 6 will be coming soon
however the last chapter was posted in
2014 so we're pretty sure that won't
happen
nevertheless the last chapter kind of
finishes on a good note anyway so you
definitely won't feel disappointed if
you read this story if you love easily
readable and feel-good fanfics
this is the one to watch the beauty
within okay we're moving on to some of
the more mature fan fictions that
probably aren't suitable for a younger
generation this story belongs to Sakura
one-two-one from the archive of our own
org it gets a little bit dark at times
but it definitely features an
interesting Disney perspective the story
mainly involves Beauty and the Beast
characters with a bit of a twist in this
fan fiction
Belle is applying for a maid job in the
princes castle well actually she has no
choice but to work there to stop her
father from being sent to prison
she actually hopes she never has to
encounter the prince because well he's
not exactly the nicest person he's
actually quite a beast that's extremely
power hungry we won't spoil it all for
you but let's just say
you'll definitely enjoy it the entire
fanfiction is split into twenty-six
impressive chapters and it comes with
more than twice as many words as a
regular novel it's definitely a long
read so we recommend grabbing your
tablet or a Kindle and enjoy it like a
proper book as of October 2018 this
story is still in progress so who knows
you might find new chapters by the time
you watch this video it's a surprise the
magic of Hogwarts and we're back to
Harry Potter we just can't help it we
absolutely love Disney and Harry Potter
crossovers they're just so pure and they
bring together everything we love Disney
Princesses are already magical but a
little Harry Potter magic never hurt
nobody this fanfiction can be found on
archive of our own org and it belongs to
color my world bright one of the reasons
we love this fanfiction is because it
pretty much includes every Disney
character ever from Disney Princesses to
characters from other movies this fanfic
has it all and obviously for that reason
it's pretty long like 16 chapters and
100,000 words long seriously there's so
much Disney princess interaction on this
one we promise you're going to love
every single one the story is quite
simple it just talks about Adventures of
Disney characters at Hogwarts it's
marked as a story meant for teenage ages
and up due to the nature of its words
you might also see plenty of LGBTQ
characters taking place as well as
straight relationships let's just say
there's a lot going on and we're totally
here for it seriously give the magic of
Hogwarts a go oh do you know you don't
like it if you won't try it
sleepover at disney castle this
fanfiction
was basically foreshadowing
wreckit-ralph two's sleepover moment we
saw in the trailers it's a pretty simple
story but we absolutely love this fan
fiction you can fight it on
fanfiction.net in a belongs to a rubber
butt girl it's actually one of the few
fan fictions that are super short well
at least for the ones we've mentioned
today as the title suggests Disney
Princesses want to have a sleepover at
Disney Castle
they're basically tired of their work
schedule and they just want a bit of fun
but they also have to make sure that is
boys don't attempt to crash the party
and trust us they do this is a
completely innocent story suitable for
all ages and it's absolutely adorable
we just love seeing all the Disney
Princesses interact with each other oh
yeah and Mary Poppins makes an
appearance in this one as well and the
princesses are watching Titanic and mr.
and mrs. Smith which is just hilarious
if you're looking for a short feel-good
story give this one a try who knows
these fan fictions might even give you
some inspiration to write your own WD
Academy and here it is the story you've
been waiting for you can find it on
fanfiction.net and it belongs to a user
called Amira 777 WD Academy is all about
a boarding school where you can find all
your favorite Disney characters
seriously everyone you love and everyone
you don't love is in this story this
story covers everything from musical
numbers to school crushes and hookups
although there aren't any graphic scenes
in there it still might not be suitable
for everyone as it's more written for
teenage audiences but it's still a
fantastic story of Disney characters
being basically sent to boarding school
some of the chapters are short others
long giving you a good balance and
motivation to read right to the end by
the looks of it this story was never
finished however it kind of wraps up in
a way when you get to the end so even
though you might not get the typical
happy ending you will still get an
ending and there you have it we bet you
have a Disney fan fiction you've always
wanted to write or maybe you were just
inspired by these fan fictions either
way come tell us all about it in the
comments below we want to know
absolutely everything about it and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]